what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation I am rejoined by Aaron the
Alexander Aaron how are you I am doing
fantastic Greg I am ready to watch this
James Gunn movie debut this is his first
movie it's his first movie yeah we
thought we'd watch this before he ruins
the DC Universe ruins Superman that's
gonna be fun I'm excited for his DC
Universe and it's gonna be like a fun
little game to see like oh this actor
has carried on in the James Gunn
Pantheon of films blah blah blah here
he's in those early earmarks you see
some Michael Rooker probably probably
yeah is he in this I I imagine anyway
guys you know it's a deal please go
ahead and leave a like on this video and
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification on because we are covering
so many movies here on the Chanel I hear
this movie is uh YouTube I hear there's
a lot of a lot of craziness in this film
and uh just know that you know none of
it's real all right just know that
YouTube it's not gonna hurt you
as always full-length region watch along
where you sync up with your own copy
available for all of our super sexy
rejects that was a lot of patrons and
thank you to all who've been joining our
patreon page it is one of the blessings
of the reject Nation also covers several
things exclusive their reaction Heights
Watch Dogs included let's get to it
a meteor a floating turd this might be
the only James got movie I haven't seen
too really yeah wow
even super that's fun I've seen super
yeah Ripper will flies about 27 miles an
hour I'd have thought more like
[Laughter]
normally I didn't fill in tell you
exactly how fast it's going within two
miles per hour it's fascinating he looks
so young I was just thinking about
Babyface Nathan
um
what a great capture the juxtaposition
yeah
okay Monster cam will Sam Rainey dead
sounds like a little pulse in there that
was a really well constructed opening
with capturing the small town flare
right up front with this Larger than
Life entity coming here it's Global
threat yeah yeah the contrast yeah
[Music]
oh this guy's a great actor
I look so familiar from
hey I'll do it mayor
live life to the fullest Darwin said
fittest
things in this movie what the hell we're
smarter but we're neophytes the
Cockroach that fellow's been around 300.
oh my God
teenagers which of us is the more
successful species
that is the question of the movie
is that James Gunn oh [__] yeah
recognize him behind there's Michael
Rucker hey there he is yup free
white-haired white bearded gun
I know what he wants to borrow
I don't see like an abusive husband
's mother left her daddy's a drunk she's
17 years old old Grandpa's up big old
Cadillac I don't know what an authentic
accent is but that sounds authentic
I believe them
damn Michael Rooker was cut ripped
Rucker
oh man even sweet he looks so creepy
yeah because I said he got her when she
was 17. why don't you just work one out
for yourself though
I'm just not in the mood okay tail
it's so uncomfortable yeah
yeah when the hell are you in the
morning
[Music]
where's he going where are you going
out
for walk he's salty
I know all there is to know about the
cross
this feels for some reason I keep
flashing a peacemaker you know like the
vibe of this I can just figure of
comparing it to like modern day James
Gunn yeah yeah this feels like something
that would happen in that for sure yeah
especially this scene right here
[Music]
yep it goes back to the apartment she's
a weird alien my sister Megan she was a
big fat old cow and I'd be thinking
is he seeing her that ain't me you
couldn't been more than 10 or 11. hell
that was game cheater
creepy cheater
listen to the bird it's a warning sign
the crow knows the crows always know
oh
damn okay
I can't don't do it
she just won't worry about me
you're gonna have to explain how you
found this thing
oh Trail
I don't know I'm just not the kind of
guy who would follow the trail I'm good
yeah get the hell out of there I get
curious to try to watch this from as far
of a distance I would take my camera and
try to see as far as it can go and then
I'm going to call someone if you like
you should look into this yeah
don't
on
come on so that wouldn't be me no way
hell no I'm out ah nope nope nope
[Music]
it's so gross
whoa what X-ray vision x-ray vision it's
the last thing I expected to see oh God
in his throat
on his brains make it over okay white
people love to go to the woods bro this
couldn't couldn't be me couldn't be me
hey Middle Eastern people sometimes go
to
amateur and black people
who it is
a little nose that's where I would it's
good that'll no thank you
how fun it has the if it has a flare of
like a whole bunch of other horror
movies already Evil Dead alien little
Predator yeah
definitely a little predator for sure
x-ray vision and stuff the thing I've
never seen it but I'm I'm sure
meat Feast mate gotta eat that mate
Telltale sign that you're corrupted when
you eat it raw
[Laughter]
God Elizabeth Banks is just so
unattractive
gross even today
repulsive she's so gross I don't even I
can't stop looking I can't stop looking
at energy
laughs
uh what is he doing throwing into the
leaves it's getting comfy make himself a
little nest
oh oh now she wants to play the
seduction game now she's in the mood now
he used the guilt card does that work
[Laughter]
put guilt in defense
fail proof
[Laughter]
that's awesome oh my God I just slept
cut back to her so I could see how gross
she is
so does this like prey on its most
Primal senses to the extreme bloodlust
sexual loss yes or no find out
he seems more confused and turned on are
you crying
is he he's sad oh he's conflicted
because the monster wants to kill her
but he loves his wife
don't do that
oh it's gonna Slither in your mouth
oh God I don't like it I think he's
gonna slow their thinner
nope hey what's this I don't want it not
not one bit it's just little bug bud
that could be fleas
checked out there eh
[Laughter]
it's been a while
[Music]
laughs
so how co-workers talk I think so yeah
always calling the woman who come here
that use
I'm telling you this morning
us it's a real changing Grant you can
say something like that
Nate me how to Mr Grant me oh hey there
give me a couple of your rib eyes how
many you need eight
[Laughter]
give me 14. you're having a party a
little surprise for the wife
damn
baby where are our savings I thought
Nathan Fillion would be the main
character right you think so or maybe
it's just like the opening too until
interesting structure so far right right
it's all busted up
[Laughter]
the body horror that you could feel is
just building yeah the impending doom of
the body horror a little bit of the fly
as well
someone I've never seen
oh don't eat that dog is he gonna eat
the dog he's gonna eat Skipper oh does
it turn you into just like always keep
saying meat so it's like turn your neck
of the cannibals and stuff yeah
don't pop it oh God this is gonna pop
some [__] I can't take a pimple dude no
way no freaking way oh there's gonna be
some fun makeup designs
turn around so I could see how repugnant
you are
[Laughter]
oh no these sounds the the sound designs
yeah gross especially we have headphones
on right reaps into the ears uh what the
hell James Gunn I could have just
blurred this on YouTube
[Laughter]
cowards clearly he thought she was gross
too
yeah whoa
[Music]
oh what is going on I don't like it oh
God that was unexpected I thought this
[__] like this would happen way later
right wasn't those fleshy Cheeto was
that sentient Cheeto puff
oh wants to mate with her and it's
rawest he's conflicted
yeah the human in him is still there
I gotta go to work
I will never understand there's a black
guy grown man two two of them two black
people winning
this town she's saying what it used to
be man
never seen trauma but I understand the
reference yep
we actually got to open every door I am
dead
it's good at playing creepy that's his
main trick
oh does humble have feelings for her I
think he does what you doing oh nothing
just I'm trying to get a buzz on but I
can't
I can't do buff got too much muscle mass
I don't know what it is
I'm too strong with all these muscles
it's interesting seeing him play a more
relatable guy instead of
cocky douchebag you know it's usually
right just the smart-ass wise guy yeah
it's kind of chilly tonight yeah
yeah oh he's not just talking about the
the skyline he's talking about
this hideous woman here
like Thomas right
she's conflicted I have a husband
oh he's gonna totally Slaughter this one
oh he's gonna kill the poop out of her
try not to cuss
ing
[Laughter]
over the fish in the sea
and over the birds of the air and over
every living thing that a baby with
tomato ah there's a bit of an atom
quality is it tomato or an apple
Tomatoes Tomatoes I was confused even if
it wasn't Apple why do you go to baby an
apple
no no no no no no no no no no ready to
see this I don't want to
I'm ready to see this it's not ready oh
I'm not ready you're gonna kill it
oh no
nope
this is disturbing poor baby and woman
of course
where does it feed
it's gonna go in her belly oh it's so
gross
that was disgusting
no not the not this thing not the pokey
poke
[Music]
I hate this this is really gross
what's it's like a succubus what's it
what's it feeding on is it feeding off
or is it going inside I think it's
putting more of itself into her okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
that's so bad that's so messed up dark
twisted humor man
[Music]
there's this Vibe about this movie that
feels like a classic you went to
Blockbuster and just picked it randomly
off the shelf kind of uh yeah like we're
gonna watch this on a Friday night whoa
oh my God baby what happened to your
face
it's just a beast
yeah the makeup is wild we gotta get you
to the hospital no no no no
I already saw Dr Carl he said
things like this happen really
no
look a bit like that
performance is really good in this movie
you see his conflict you feel the
suffering within him as well yeah
oh you felt that changing him huh
[Music]
Roscoe he's eating the dogs
she was able to put it together
it's all connected
[Music]
oh she's morphing into something
oh what is she turning into you see that
it's not turning into there's a lower
half there's something off of her lower
half yeah I see it do you know what
Brenda Gutierrez no
her eyes are so blue girl disappeared
Friday night signs of a struggle in the
house people saw Grant going into her
house oh God
it must have been someone that looks
like Grant
yeah Grant has a lot of very
distinguishable
creepy figures about his face give me a
call as soon as he gets you
I do like the writing of how we get to
know the characters just through the
interactions they have not about like
laying down a bunch of backstory or
something oh yeah the subtext of it yeah
well written and directed successful for
a reason
foreign
never go in the basement you've not seen
any horror movie oh is it gonna be a
bunch of dead dogs I want to see that if
that's the case
and that's what I call a hell no
oh
damn
oh oh God that isn't worse than what I
thought it would be oh that's so
disturbing
[Music]
oh my God damn Jesus this is so violent
yeah yeah I don't think they just they'd
do that in a movie today
oh please go back and he's gone right
now please do it please do it
oh
[Music]
a huge house
oh come on
why are you running for me baby
now it's like a domestic Thriller I
can't trust you no more
oh my God
it's never not gross
[Applause]
his arm is becoming old
whoa It's all slithery
that's the word
whoa he's a tentacle arm what the hell
oh man that was wild wow wow now we're
cooking oh it really it does a great job
with that like old school B movies
sci-fi alien schlock yeah oh three days
later and especially with having that
sign at the beginning of the movie with
the specific uh billboard and the the
way the music is done too it's
definitely throwback for sure we need to
find this grant I mean yesterday Town
Council lit a Roman Candle stuck it up
my ass Jack your leisure activities
ain't my business now he's the main
character
yeah that's interesting that's a really
interesting structure
she heard you say squid she's going to
go out and create a guy
today Bill ah Jenna Fisher his ex-wife
oh is this when they were married they
were together while she was in the
office you said it was dark you don't
know what the hell you saw his arm was
all bendy mayor well it's obvious guy
Lyme disease
yeah that's it that makes you look like
a squid
another attack over at the cast of bets
she's playing a reception that's good
yeah
it's what you know
two nights ago a mayor was stolen from
this property owned by if it's given
that Rancher with the cleft palate yeah
your mom weren't too proud when you came
out neither Wally
had our next is going to end up here
a family called The Strip Myers we're
gonna have to go there tonight Lalo and
wait what's going get that son of a
[__] sheep Mr Pibb extra
oh this music it's straight out of
Predator
okay from them jokers wanted to use it
we should be all right before we go ah
we're using the third act baby let's go
third at grenade it's cool this movie
like transitions into different types of
alien sci-fi horror movies yeah take a
love letter to a different ones it
interweaves throughout yeah how unless
you bring Grant back alive your only
chance of doing that is with me bring
her she's the main supporting character
you guys have to fall in love she has to
come
thank you for these guys next victims I
guess okay good I want those little
girls to die
there's Jack
I want you all to stay inside tonight
you're here I would love to go to the
South I feel like we'd fit right we
would be highly welcome
especially when the Sun goes down yeah
man especially you oh yeah dude oh my
God it's your favorite love me yeah
not time we're kids
you came knocking on my window in the
middle of that oh he remembers so well
vividly my sister what the hell you
doing out there she says
if she's going to run away to Hollywood
and be a big star so she says she needs
a bodyguard and invites me to come along
and I said Starlight oh dude you missed
your chance you could take care of
herself
I think it's you she looks like a
floating head
[Laughter]
she'll fit in great with that kid from
Thor's love and thunder and Ezra Miller
and Flash from the get-go he's so [__]
[__] up our Fame unfortunately you
floating head some [__] look at a
sincere kind guy perfect time to head on
her when you're on your her husband's a
murdering Rampage right
clean in
what has he morphed into where are you
evolution is much bigger than I thought
I love good makeup man
[__]
let's cut its head off what are we gonna
do now bill
cuffs won't even fit on them
third grade alive this is concerned
can't handcuff him because it won't even
fit on him
we'll get the car all slimy
same bill or Dale forgot I don't know
one of them
one of them I'll tell you what Hank
God damn it Bobby
France whoa
oh good nasty damn they really put him
in that makeup right I don't know how
long that took we're just here
take you to get some help
right now that is insane that mouth to
like the prosthetic mouth transition
it's actually making my stomach a little
queasy that rarely happens oh God it's
making me hungry it feels turned inside
out hungry
oh it actually is really uh hibachi
[Laughter]
that is truly gross yeah
you say you don't want to eat that no
stop right there you son of a [__]
you're dead we need to find that girl
now you can make his peaceful
or you can make it hard that's all I got
that guy shot right there that guy lying
[Laughter]
I love the way how it's realized yeah oh
James Gunn please come back to horror
man stuck true to that I know this makes
me go produce that Swamp Thing movie man
right right
you afraid
it's like way in the back
easy for you to say back there uh he's
the one I identify with the most
[Laughter]
yeah he's not gonna be dead oh no
wow what a great title it is literally
the verb to describe boy and it moves
that's that's a great title yeah and
also it describes like the texture I
love a good title love a good title man
very fitting
oh no what has she morphed into I was
just thinking of the same thing
don't be a sore loser great little
character trait I love those little
nuances my question is who's the one
black dude who's not a cop that's with
him I've never addressed it
oh no no
I did not expecting I'm sorry the years
oh Jesus oh I hate it I hate it so much
what the [__]
ah
no one seeing me like this oh my god oh
no
what is happening
Brenda
[Music]
get the get out of there just go I'm so
I'm so [__] hungry
I never knew anyone could be so hungry
what oh my God
that that possum over there oh God
yep
yep that black guy should have some
sense too you need to get out of there
bro we better get you to the hospital
right quick Hospital you're in a
hospital bill shut up
[Music]
nope nope
[Laughter]
It's Gonna Pop
oh
no no no no
oh the bastard let us here oh my God
whoa what is that what is that
[Music]
no no no no no no no no cover your mouth
no no put your mouth on Earth what are
you doing what are you doing what are
you doing I hate this I hate this I hate
this I hate this
no no no no no no no no no no no no
wow how did you guys all survive oh my
God
he's lying he's just trying to act like
yeah no no the other one's died
instantly alien wised up no alien toy
got in him
oh no it's gonna Slither in somebody's
bath oh it's like that Friday the 13th
maybe not forever on the street I
haven't seen those either
wait who's she I want to see more of her
she's a brand new
oh this movie is so smart
honey you're gonna turn into a plum in
there prune mama I know what turns into
what so once you finish up in there and
get yourself into bed you're here is
this movie gonna suggest where it goes
oh God or it slithers into is that what
they're gonna do I think it is Somewhere
Out There Kevin foggy was like this guy
should make Guardians of the Galaxy
man clearly has a vision
Goosebumps this has that Goosebumps
flare totally it's hitting it's hitting
all the checks right now
going to her vagina oh God
dude I was joking
this
no we're actually gonna do this please
God don't do it
[Music]
that's mean
get it out get it out get it out get it
out
thank you
oh
we can see the whole history of the
worlds it's conquered oh it's like a
high of mine right did not expect to get
that
this is like the movie We just watched
oh is that easy to kill it oh never mind
you injured it I think
yeah burn that [__]
burn it yeah cook him cook him
hahaha
[Music]
no you're not gonna kill the kids I know
you're not about to kill them I think
they should kill the kids
[Music]
good movie Kill the kids that's what you
do
established whoa yeah you're screwed get
out of there girl jump out the window
okay heat can hurt them so they need
like actual fire torches
you didn't break your legs wow you
really know how to fall young she drinks
milk
high calcium strong bones
the keys of course you don't got the
damn Keys you gotta learn how to hotwire
real quick
wow what a cool shot it's swallowing you
alive all right you three get these
folks out of the bar and all the rotten
stance you can't be doing them any good
you take this I got my coat
there's always been an ensemble
filmmaker hasn't he
I think so you're gonna Slither on the
deer too it's goddamn biological weapons
that's what it is government
Wheels you know why because I don't take
no [__] from nobody that does stay here
they want to
kiss my ass how'd this guy become mayor
James Gunn was onto something
ahead of his time marriage
it's a second my
mind just like you say oh it's a real
hive mind I'm sorry for trying to
strangle you know
I lost my
head or it's just one being
afraid you wouldn't love me no more
quite
you better set back down you don't look
so good hey oh
it's getting worse by the second
sir it's the full-on zombie movie right
now
she has a point just like open it come
on love the depraved nature of these
characters
[Applause]
what is that yeah
is it acid oh
foreign
don't hesitate shoot this Slither too
well [__]
[Music]
is there no way to save them once they
infect them or you can never get it out
I'm gonna guess
maybe if you tickle them maybe that'll
get it out they hate tickling shock them
sweat it out maybe you could like sweat
it out put them in a sauna or something
yeah
oh business as usual yeah
he's gonna come with me hey damn
from that one body of one consciousness
of that one alien okay
friends are still out there Trevor
the heck is going on
I love the choice where he really
watches his he does like the childish
swearing it says like dang it darn it
heck
[Laughter]
oh damn she's Gotten Good at murdering
right that'll get her done
Jesus
I think my question is I guess we have
to wait till the finale but what value
did adding this other character bring to
the film
thanks
man after all that murder and she still
looks like not sweating no blood
repulsive
and no I have such fiends of contempt
for her looks
but
I need you to get the CDC on the horn
for me okay I'll get you right back
Tree in her front yard where it's got in
his pipes it messes with the whole
system on with me you took a big [__]
don't you lie
oh oh
oh
[Music]
God I'm gonna fall into your mouth
James Gunn putting his ex-wife and stuff
a habit he will never repeat yeah
oh yep that's her value in the story
because she saw the the hive mind oh yes
she's the only Survivor to see it
this is Jack or it's a general term
meaning outer space [__]
oh
now he's here but the fire stopped this
love spreads grows absorbing the minds
and bodies of the organisms around it
if I worry about [__] in my pants I'd be
fascinated you were just like teaching a
class that kind of pertains to the
situation at hand here Shelby did you
get the CDC for me we're at the city
limits welcome back
killer
[Music]
watch out
oh this should be such a great excuse to
kill everyone you know what I mean
totally finally wipe the towel clean
from all these annoying people wipe away
the race to start a new
at least she's safe she's the chosen one
we're the Guardians when you need them
[Music]
it's black
different man we had a few hey I mean
the preference when they go to church
and congregate and all that and they're
listening to a black that means this
town is not a racist I'm sure only a few
people have a problem
themselves
[Laughter]
I wonder why it is all the best conflict
movie directors start with either
thriller or horror movies
oh that's a deer
I think so it's a weird looking deer
oh you're screwed if you got bit
you're infected
that's a fascinating design
she's Brave now
yeah Grenade third at grenade we gotta
go oh once one sees us they all see us
really it was obvious but I called it
is our Queen most protect our Queen yeah
they're dragging these bodies too Lord
you think that'll lead us to Miss Grant
don't you Now where's James Gunn and all
this did he get slithered on or is he
chilling at home somewhere I probably
got slurred on I'm not hoping they kill
her off kill the wife off yeah
do they have the balls too it'd be a
pretty bold move
oh yeah where'd they put him
or is this the feeding ground I hear
some weird noises probably means you're
gonna get eight homie
don't you look at me like that
It's gotta be like a king and a queen
right like I'm taking it that's the case
we're screwed yep so interesting so he's
the only other person besides the girl
in the beginning to get
the direct tentacles so what's gonna
happen to him
I do like how they realize that the
Korean personalities there's kind of
like a Texas Chainsaw Massacre vibe to
them the queen personality yes it's like
super excuse bile all the time very
angry and sensitive
see not morphing into anything I think
he is morphing he's gonna eat her
oh we just gave it in okay
oh damn you're like a shrine to her
oh man
oh God
that is a wild design ah it's horrifying
it's kind of like a centipede of sorts
yeah it's coming out of the house damn
there's a worm heads that's where
they're bringing the bodies
track the bodies on the floor Drive the
bodies on them that's where they're
joining together
oh gross
how icky
well now that is some dumb [__] you got
that right
[Music]
how emotionally volatile the creatures
are
not to go through some adjustments after
all these changes what is it exactly
huge job decorating baby
no you don't want to hurt me Grant
you like being called Grant there is a
strange tragedy to this character yeah I
felt that from the beginning
you don't have to be alone we could be
together I never had much use for this
world anyway
it's got eyes and ears everywhere while
you do what you need to do
because it's your nature don't kiss
don't kiss
just shot him in the face you stab him
in the face you wouldn't have had that
happen I would have gone for the eyeball
kill me party please
[__] [__]
how long do they have before it goes
where the hell the feathers come from
what the hell
dude Jesus
underhand underhand ah no
oh no
I love that subvert those expectations
a whole ass couch
it's pretty wild that they've did all
this this is gonna look like the ending
of peacemakers
oh no
oh God he's finishing
[Music]
after the tent to go there's like
there's really creepy sexual undertones
yeah yeah
good thing happens
propane
that was convenient yeah
[Music]
oh no is it gonna kill him too
gross cover your mouth
it's a whole lot better yep naturally
the hive mind Falls there's a whole dead
ass Town only two of you all survived
the sexual deviant qualities you're just
like that's so unsettling to me it's
like just like things you just really
get under your skin
I feel morally compromised right now
of course she's fine she had a couch to
block her from the explosion
Holding Out for a Hero to the end of the
night come on move faster
no way
I live now you live with him you need
both of them things and you to get all
woomy oh that's awesome
yeah oh
this is awesome
just moving on she's moving on might as
well he's dead
man you got to repopulate this town
Bishop Bill's just a few miles down the
tent at that hospital there with the
green stupid thing up top if the
hospital's still up and running now one
of the aliens have time to board up the
windows
surprise he never made a sequel to this
one maybe he didn't make enough money
but that's probably yeah that's likely
well they have called it the slithering
Slither the slither
slithers slithers is a plural
two Slither to Slytherin
uh it's Slytherin
Slither live Slither too
um Slither on Slither Slither Origins
Slither Resurrection Slither
Resurrection
Slither Generations
is good
Slither ending explained breakdown
Easter eggs how it should have slithered
I watched Slytherin 0.25 speed and
here's what I found honest slithers
Slither pitch
what a cool ending shot they're still
walking it's still going
hold it
wow what's gonna happen out of the town
everything's going to be prosperous you
think it's going to find its footing
again I mean there's a lot of land they
could uh there's a lot of commercial you
know right a lot of real estate
potential is what I'm getting at a lot
of real estate this can now become a
tourist attraction they can make money
from the people that died you know
profit on their Advance what I would do
if I was in their situation right now
considered in fact there's a lack of
surveillance is go through everyone's
pockets and try to just grab as much
money as you can right no I'm talking
about like just diamonds jewelry nothing
that's like checking account credit
cards like like cash or cold cash that
way uh that that's what I would do at
least in a situation like how many how
many mattresses full of cash do you
think you're just in that town oh God
there's got to be at least one person
there who's like oh they've been living
amongst a small town but they made their
living off of being like a drug dealer
or something and they probably have oh
loads again the mayor probably has so
much corrupt money just lying around
much Mr Pibb so much Mr pip too yeah Mr
PIV for days yeah there's a lot a lot of
ways that you could take advantage of
the situation true
I get uh
I'd probably take all the cash yeah
do you think there's a post credit scene
there might be I don't know it's an
early gun who knows
oh there is there will be let's wait
let's let's wait for let's just skip to
it all right we're gonna escape to it
[Music]
Goosebumps The Girl Who Cried Monster
the girls scared me okay inspiration
[Music]
wow they're doing post credit scenes
back then huh
oh brain
no
no it lives not the cat it's a kitty cat
I was looking at they trained the cat to
lick it
that's mean
what's with the animal abuse I don't
know James's gonna have something
against animals clearly
Jesus Christ man back off the animals
gun the Superman movie's gonna be full
of like she's gonna murder crypto the
dog right four seconds yeah
yeah right
it also use some live ones too what's
the deal man what's the dealio what's
your problem James gone God you like it
I did I had a lot of fun
I had a lot of fun with that
that was better than I was expecting
I've heard nothing but good things but
it exceeded my expectations too it
exceeded your expectations yeah because
I really truly expected it to be like a
[__] four dollar film really yeah I
don't know well this is his first film
so I thought he had like a low low
budget I didn't I knew I had a feeling
Michael Rucker would be in it but I
didn't know about the other stars
but yeah I thought it was a lot of fun I
thought it was very cleverly
constructed that it clearly has a lot of
love for horror films of the past it
used tropes that we're familiar with
it's averted some other tropes the
effects and the practice the visual
effects and the Practical effects were
both incredible
uh for the time and for now that's right
right visual it's like the okay VFX
I know stuff uh it was good it was like
makeup effects makeup effects yeah I
thought the acting was really good I
thought that I had a good
I don't know I really enjoyed the way
that Michael Rucker was able to play
with both playing this creepy character
but also was able to show like the
monster side of it it was there was
there was Nuance in his performance and
this alien possession thing and it was
just an enjoyable film overall it had
some really disturbing things it was
surprisingly funny and yeah it
it's interesting seeing the start of
where gun kind of took off from and what
we know him to be today with the
Guardians film with things like
Peacemaker and and Suicide Squad yeah
and yeah dude it was really dope yeah I
like the I like the portrayal of Michael
rooker's character a lot because
it seems whatever this creature is
bonds because like becomes in symbiosis
with the
with the actual personality of the
character yeah you know it's and like it
was took off because like the way they
handled Michael rooker's introduction
here has been just a normal person he he
really did love his wife like he really
did love her even when he was like
tempted to cheat he actually didn't go
through like she jumped on him and then
it was like a second later like I can't
yeah you know and even and they clearly
established like this guy's been because
they're setting you up like ah he's just
like a really horny guy or something you
know he's super he's just a horn dog and
he's a he's a creep and he's Michael
Rooker so you know we know that's what
Michael Rooker is probably in real life
too that's why he always plays these
people because he's a pervert Oriole
this is a nasty human being here that's
why he always plays nasty people can't
trust that guy I would never want to be
around Michael Rooker
I don't think I would
there's just something about it it's
just like I don't know you give me the
tingles man there's nothing about you I
just feel like I have my penis would
shriveled around you so you're gonna do
something to me
so I'm supposed to hug you man I don't
know I don't know I just feel like it's
like listen son because he's like yeah I
couldn't do it man
um she's a really creepy guy it's a big
deal the reason is always playing creepy
people
um but she's good he's really good so I
thought the setup of him was really well
orchestrated because he I thought it was
going to go a more cliche path like ah
he was going to have this affair and
because of the affair that's how he
found the alien but now they took a very
different approach and weirdly enough
when he the more he morphs into an alien
it might be the time that's hardest for
him uh because
he's got a truly cap because Michael
Rooker has that ability to be very
off-putting for the creepy ways be
simultaneously Charming while being
creepy but then also just this great
depth of sadness in his eyes yeah you
know and you really needed that for the
monster portrayal uh at the very end I
like the way that was realized so it was
kind of a neat structure to start it off
where it's so much about him in the
First Act
when he's really the the villain of the
story you know and there's a and it has
this combined tragedy of the character
uh I thought it was really that was
really weird how they did that structure
is my only recollection of anything from
this movie was like a commercial that I
remember Nathan phillian being in it so
I just assumed he was the lead
um
and then he's nowhere near as
interesting of a character is
that I mean these are the most
interesting characters oh yeah yeah like
by a long shot uh like maybe the
feelings charming and he's good he's
serviceable I think I think everyone's
good I think everyone's really good and
they're all very fitting and they bring
their personalities to life uh but yeah
I didn't I wasn't very
uh I think what James Gunn has evolved
as a writer and a director is that while
doing crazy intricate plots is getting
you to really root for them uh for this
characters on the on the emotional
Journey they have to go on as well yeah
you know specifying his uh Ensemble and
the characters we're following I feel
like this one is very much Michael
Rooker was like the lead in The First
Act of the story but then for the most
part everything after that became about
the event itself itself and these are
just the the vehicles in which we're
following this story within the small
town exactly and he's he's really Gotten
Good at having both strong characters
and strong plots yeah because this film
is all about this is mainly about the
immediacy of the situation and and like
I thought I did a really good job on the
like it was gross it was mainly gross it
was it wasn't violence I wouldn't call
it scary no I wouldn't call it
suspenseful but I really felt it was
trying to be that while also being
self-aware and tongue-in-cheek and
having that fun you know I think it was
trying to be at the qualities of of like
a Sam Raimi of the horror of Sam Raimi
where where you are this variety of
qualities you know and but it was but
because
the
the journey like I thought there was
stuff planted like okay yeah Nathan
Fillion likes Elizabeth Banks he has
feelings probably in love with her sure
um but yeah there was there's something
about like you always need kind of a a
little bit more of a of a of an
underlying motivation or or more of a
heart or something like that to really
connect to and I think that's what James
Gunn really really exceeds now you know
um and I think he's just become more
refined as that as a writer and a
director so that way you you remain as I
noticed my emotional investment was kind
of dwindling towards the end like the
last 20 minutes I was like yeah this is
a short movie but I'm also ready to call
it yeah I found myself getting ready to
call it when when I noticed that when it
wasn't wrapped up in violence or practic
or crazy practical effects
it was after
um I guess it was after the whole bug
thing and the and the and the girl we
meet in the bathtub with the family when
it was mainly just becoming like the
crazies invasion of body snatcher zombie
or whatever you want to call it where
it's just mainly humans who are
attacking I was noticing my interest and
it was actually starting to dip yeah
because it was picked back up when it
got to Michael Rooker and monstrosity
form yeah because it was less
interesting something like we can we're
familiar with so it wasn't like I don't
know I think the threat of like little
worms are like a giant worm person is
more interesting than watching a bunch
of people like what you're from like
Creature Feature to zombie and like yeah
Creature Feature typically is more
interesting or even more scary than
zombie but like but I kind of agree with
you I was never actually scared during
the movie I was more grossed out yeah
and kind of just like freaked out but
never like felt like I needed to like
truly cover my eyes like this is going
to keep me up at night kind of thing but
I will say that though the character
work itself wasn't the strongest I will
say that the kind of something we
brought up while we're watching the
movie was the fact that the subtext of
like their characters relationships was
there without outright saying it like
you can tell that their relationship
release that instance from the night of
their relationship between Michael
Rucker and Elizabeth Banks character
wasn't like the strongest she wasn't in
the mood and he was like frustrated by
that kind of implying that they've had
these problems before and then you saw
like the connection between Elizabeth
Banks and Nathan fillings character
implying that this isn't their first
interaction before that they've had like
denying feelings for one another so I
thought that stuff was good but I think
the the specificity of like what makes
these people these people was kind of
lacking also the girl in the third act
that was added at the house yeah she was
just kind of there and she literally
only served the point of uh Exposition
and kind of giving the characters uh
knowledge into where where these people
are from because I felt like James Gunn
was like oh we need an explanation for
like where these people came from uh
she's gonna get a vision while it's
crawling their mouth she was the only
one who managed to pull it out yeah
like uh yeah I like the way they played
with the I like the sequences of
violence a lot and like I said
everyone's good uh and I really mean
that like Nathan fillings really good
Elizabeth Banks I think is is really
strong here too yeah I think they
elevate what was lacking in the in the
writing like Michael Rooker is just the
best reading one of them all and and I
love the way that
I do like the way how it factors into
who he is as a character prior to where
when he just becomes a monster he
doesn't just only remain monster there's
like a Universal Studios monster movie
tragic quality about which I really like
um and I yeah yeah I mean I thought I
was gonna repeat myself yeah I guess
that that's where I think James Gunn has
really excelled even more so now is even
just the personalities
nowadays even if there's like not much
even if it's not really about the depth
you connect to on a character the
personalities you'll connect with even
more now uh with his writing so I think
even something like even like the
suicide squad which is like more
jam-packed with [__] I'm like oh I
really cared about everyone and by the
end of that film you know and here I'm
like uh yeah I don't really I don't
really care about Nathan Fillion yeah
like he's fun he's like he's a good
actor he's a good even feeling yeah yeah
exactly like there's they have their
moments where they're really Charming
but if he died I would have been like
all right yeah you know just like how it
was nothing how the uh the mayor died
like everybody who's a fun character
that he played that character very well
but then like he kind of died really
quickly yeah I didn't really care that
much I think it's funny I think uh
there's there's a little bit more oomph
there's a little bit more
um
uh boisterous qualities to I think the
personalities he does now where he knows
how to make everyone more unique and
distinguishable not that these
characters weren't indistinguishable
from each other it's their the
specificity of their portrayals I think
are stronger now but this is him getting
his feet wet this is gonna be like his
first movie you know so it is kind of
interesting to look back and you can see
the potential of like oh if we like if
we just watch this and I've seen his
other movies and be like oh you can see
where he could evolve as a filmmaker
yeah and then but Noah is now as a
filmmaker like oh well he's achieved
that you know he's just gotten better
over the years but this is like a fun
B-movie thing that would like come on
cable or something like that and I think
that's sort of the vibe that it's aiming
for right off the bat like they
established that tone right away like
that's what they're going for they're
not trying to be this this thing with
depth or something like that
um but still I think there was something
there that could have helped aided a tad
bit more that way I was because I I did
find myself slightly checking out
towards the last like half hour the last
20 minutes of this film I would say I
was like slightly checking out I'm like
and this is this is getting a little bit
like yeah you're going by the numbers
you got to fill out that movie run time
I mean I thought the thing with the
grenade I expect them to use that next
supported that like there's certainly
yeah yeah yeah I thought things were
still working it got it got better
that's something I got better when I got
back to the the main hook which is the
the monster Michael Rooker like that's
right talk about that chunk like a
little bit before that yeah yeah I'm
kind of bored now yeah we needed a thing
to get us from from A to B yeah yeah I
will say the biggest thing this movie
did for me though was make me want to
see with all the experiences and
knowledge Jim Gunn has now as a
filmmaker what he would do with a
Slither today yeah to see like if you
were to make a Slither too how would he
improve about upon that because I
imagine he had to work here again where
budgetary restraints and all those
things and
you know and and learning how to how to
turn obstacles into opportunities I'm
sure this was a great Learning lesson
for all that too yeah so I think this
was 2005 so that was his like filmmaking
feature filmmaking debut yeah I think
it's interesting how kind of
relating it back I guess to his career
overall so this is like a defining film
for him and his career and then like on
the 20-year anniversary of him becoming
a filmmaker he's like Dawning like
Superman like the yeah the hero of all
heroes you know so like I don't know I'm
excited to see his his Evolution as a
filmmaker oh yeah sounds like another
bringing his
his careers had like Milestones I would
say and let's see like what the next big
milestone is with with something like a
Superman it being 20 years removed from
this movie yeah now he clearly loves
this genre too of this kind of horror uh
you could see those sprinkled in a lot
of his work even today he's into fleshy
things
oh yeah he provides it especially sci-fi
horror I think he's really Dr like he
doesn't strike him as a supernatural
horror kind of guy but sci-fi even
though there you get those some of those
homages there here
um sci-fi horror it seems very apparent
he's very drawn of that you've seen it
in the suicide squad with stuff like
starro and whatever yeah you know um a
lot of the uh dark twisted humor the
tragedy of stuff with like the mom of of
uh of polka dot man in there and then
you could see the horror in Guardians 3
as well yeah a lot of that weird sexual
deviousness in in Guardians too with ego
a lot of the horrors really placed
throughout in uh I would say uh
Peacemaker too like there's a lot of
this I was like a lot of this is
reminding me of what I saw in Peacemaker
yeah a lot of this kind of went back to
that that lower budget route with
Peacemaker in that show yeah yeah yeah
and small town and Hive mine monster
yeah totally totally yeah and
um so I I and and like the southern
personalities to you know there's a lot
of that that I was definitely picking up
on uh but yeah I mean other than just
comparing it because I feel like we were
pointing out everything we liked about
it uh through throughout the experience
of watching the movie yeah I feel like
we were already pointing along I do and
I like that I do like the music and
everything and I so uh yeah this is an
enjoyable film it was fun it was it was
a really it was a really fun one and so
there's some images here that are just
that were really just really disturbing
yeah
that almost never happens to me where my
stomach starts to be like Oh I'm getting
a bit of a of a nausea feeling right now
and I rarely ever have that happen to me
but yeah that was really stomach
churning at a couple of points
um but yeah I think it's just a little
bit of
a little bit of character fleshing out
and a little bit of uh
I don't know something with the umph of
the editing I think in a certain chunk
would have helped I feel like they never
took its foot off the pedal but for the
most part really fun film once again
around Tomatoes then we'll call it a day
what's the Rotten Tomatoes score
let's see let me see I'm gonna guess I'm
gonna guess is 60. I guess a
75. all right
wow 87 way off here wow critics loved it
audiences audiences were that I was
closer with the audience audience score
is 63 percent
and then uh audience uh critic score is
87 slimy B movie homage yes definitely
affecting low budget horror films creepy
and funny if you've got the stomach
that's pretty much everything we said
all we got to do is read a Ron Spanish
feel like yeah yeah
let's just uh go off of that copy that
yeah
yeah it was close I was way off I was
really close to the audience those
people critics really loved it yeah
alrighty guys well thank you so much for
being here we'll see you all soon thank
you Aaron and share us on patreon as
well peace out
foreign